[Música]
quien no ha disfrutado de ese aromático
y el sabroso olor a tierra mojada
que nos evoca pues quizás un día de
lluvia o un día de campo
a mí me evoca mi niñez los días que
vamos acampar a marca no se puede ser
hasta un momento triste también y por
qué no eufórico pero se han puesto a
pensar porque cuando llueve o
simplemente cuando se moja el suelo
huele a tierra mojada pues son unas
bacterias aunque ustedes no lo crean hay
bacterias en el suelo que lo que hacen
es degradar todo lo que va cayendo todo
lo que ustedes imaginan que cae en el
campo imagínense un animal que cayó sus
cuernos sus pezuñas cuánto tardaría en
degradarse o desaparecer de la faz del
planeta si no existieran esas bacterias
en el suelo son maravillosas ellas se
encargan de que todos los residuos de
las hojas los insectos se vayan
degradando y entonces en ese proceso que
creen que hacen liberan una sustancia
química que se llama geox
y bueno la geosmina nos trae esa
evocación de la tierra mojada si ustedes
fueran al laboratorio donde trabajamos
en la facultad de ciencias químicas de
la universidad autónoma de chihuahua
verían esto que son las bacterias estas
bacterias aunque no estén en el campo
que las tengamos nosotros le llamamos
incubadoras y las apapachamos les damos
de comer eso que ustedes ven ahí son
unas les llamamos cajas petri pero les
damos una gelatina nutritiva que les
encanta y si ustedes se fijan se ven
diferentes colores realmente
es igual las bacterias son las que
liberan esos colores y no nada más
liberan colores liberan aromas y
entonces diríamos pues que padre y qué
más hacen pues muchísimas cosas más
ellas producen sustancias químicas para
defenderse de otros microorganismos que
ya están en el suelo como le hacen para
sobrevivir pues precisamente eso
liberando sustancias químicas de defensa
pero bueno estoy hablando maravillas de
las bacterias porque a mí me encantan
pero cuando alguien que no está en esta
área les decimos es que son bacterias
sabéis qué miedo porque me
inmediatamente pensamos en enfermedades
o las bacterias que nos descomponen los
alimentos pero créanme que solamente es
el punto 1 por ciento de las bacterias
las que nos causan enfermedades todas
las demás
benéficas y entonces si están en el
suelo
porque cuando estamos niños no nos dejan
jugar con el lodo yo siempre les digo a
mis alumnos los que tuvieron trauma de
niños que no los dejaron jugar con lodo
aquí se va a acabar su trauma entren a
mi clase y vamos a jugar con los dos nos
ponemos guantes maestra no no se pongan
guantes hay que sentir el suelo hay que
olerlo y entonces no estamos tan fuera
de la realidad el que los niños
últimamente los neurobiólogos tanto en
eeuu como en europa están pidiendo que
los niños tengan una hora de ir a
ensuciarse al lodo es parte del
aprendizaje porque esa sustancia química
que les mencionaba hace un rato la
germina activa
hormonas a nivel cerebral similar a la
serotonina y quizás si yo les digo a
serotonina a muchos no nos pueda no se
pueda captar qué es lo que quiero decir
con eso
es una sustancia química que libera a
nuestro cerebro para darnos placidez y
entonces ahora los neurobiólogos están
diciendo que estas bacterias del suelo
es el nuevo prozac y así lo están
manejando entonces decía una pedagoga
estadounidense si su niño llega limpio
de la escuela es porque no trabajo
y bueno pues si nosotros estamos en el
laboratorio constantemente trabajando
con ellas no hay excusa para que estemos
tristes verdad simplemente el abrir
donde tenemos a nuestras bacterias y
oler ese olor a jazmín nos da una nueva
sensación nos hace sentir bien pero no
nada más es eso sino que yo les estoy
platicando lo que podemos utilizar ahora
de ellas esa sensación de placidez el
que nos libere serotonina pero les puedo
hablar de ellas desde los años 40 es
desde 1940 hubo doctores como el doctor
wagner
pudo aislar una bacteria del suelo de la
cual extrajo un antibiótico que se llama
estreptomicina quizás los que se
enferman mucho de la garganta o tengan
algunas enfermedades bacterianas
continuas han de saber que sus médicos
les recetan estreptomicina y por qué se
llama así este antibiótico por esta
bacteria streptomyces
pero entonces se dieron cuenta que no
nada más producían estreptomicina sino
que hay muchísimas muchísimas bacterias
del suelo que producen antibióticos como
cloranfenicol quién sabe qué será eso
verdad pero si ustedes cuando vengan los
ventarrones ahora que no son nada raros
en chihuahua y empiezan a tener
conjuntivitis créanme que lo primero que
van a hacer es ir a comprar un gotero
para ponerse contra su conjuntivitis eso
contiene colorante nicole y lo producen
bacterias de este tipo del suelo y así
podemos hablar de muchísimas otras otros
tipos de sustancias químicas que
producen estas bacterias y entonces
dentro de toda esa gama de antibióticos
ya en aquí en la universidad de la uach
hemos aislado más de 100 cepas más de
100 tipos de bacterias diferentes y han
sido de la zona
sacramento porque tomamos muestras de
ahí de plantas que estaban creciendo los
hombres rocas sobre peñas y las plantas
estaban muy bonitas algo tiene que haber
en en esas plantas que les están
permitiendo crecer también pues
efectivamente ahí aislamos más de 100
tipos diferentes de bacterias que no
nada más permiten que la planta crezca
bien sino que están produciendo
antibióticos y entonces dijimos bueno
pues vamos a hacer un mapeo mayor o sea
que más podemos encontrar en los suelos
de chihuahua y entonces empezamos a
trabajar y se empezaron a tomar muestras
de la zona de santa isabel por
cuauhtémoc y de ahí también se aislaron
bacterias maravillosas y entonces esas
bacterias ya también las estamos
probando para saber si producen
antibióticos de qué tipo pues si los que
podamos empezamos trabajando para ver si
combatían bacterias que nos causan
diarrea
fueron efectivos si contra bacterias que
nos causan dolor de garganta en
infección en la garganta fueron
efectivos y entonces dijimos bueno
chihuahua siempre nos dicen que somos
los vencedores verdad acá del desierto
qué producción tenemos agrícola pues
frijol manzano nogal qué enfermedades
son las más comunes y entonces nos dimos
cuenta que había algunos hongos que
atacan por ejemplo el frijol al manzano
y entonces dijimos hay que poner estas
bacterias contra estas enfermedades y
están siendo efectivas que es lo que
continúa aquí que es lo que hay más que
hacer pues muchísimas cosas
desgraciadamente es
hay que hacerlo lento esto es lento las
bacterias hay que tenerlas trabajando
siempre estar verificando que realmente
no es porque yo quiera que produzcan
antibióticos se van a dar hay que
estarlo probando constantemente de tal
manera que para mí yo digo que son las
fabricas más maravillosas que hay
trabajan las 24 horas del día 7 días de
la semana y no piden vacaciones eso es
lo más maravilloso que claro que mis
tesistas tampoco tienen vacaciones junto
con sus bacterias pero créanme que
cuando entran en este mundo apasionante
de las bacterias del suelo
se les va a ser corta las vacaciones y
los fines de semana para ir a trabajar
con ellas y entonces dijimos bueno pues
si producen antibióticos vamos a ver si
también producen antifúngicos contra
hongos
también están siendo efectivas bueno
pues entonces qué es lo que ahorita
estamos viendo que se ve a nivel mundial
no nada más en chihuahua cáncer
y entonces al buscar información nos
dimos cuenta que muchas de estas
bacterias del suelo producen
antitumorales con cuatro de los cuales
tipos de cáncer de hígado de colon hay
algunos contra pulmón y ahora lo que no
se está interesando es contra cáncer de
mama y bueno entonces algunas de ellas
ya todavía no estamos trabajando en eso
es el siguiente paso pero yo les puedo
decir que si nosotros ahorita pensamos
que estamos descubriendo algo
maravilloso créanme que un filósofo
latino en el año 451 antes de cristo-
dijo que todas las plagas que emergen de
la tierra la tierra misma da el remedio
que es lo que estamos haciendo volviendo
a lo natural a lo que está en el suelo
porque de ahí inició la vida y entonces
ahora nosotros estamos diciendo que
tenemos que regresar a nuestra fábrica
de farmacia que son las bacterias del
suelo y entonces qué están haciendo
muchas compañías
por ejemplo en europa en francia están
produciendo
perfumes perfumes con olor a tierra
mojada porque porque es el nuevo
proyecto y entonces yo les preguntaría a
ustedes
dejarían que sus hijos jugaron con el
lodo yo yo sí
gracias
[Música]